[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au havre le commandant croisille a fait
au président rené coty les honneurs du
france 97 ans après la mise en service
du paquebot du même nom avec l'ancien
président de la république 400 invités
participaient à la première traverser la
manche avant l'atlantique
une répétition générale en quelque sorte
pour le commandant croisille et ses
hommes est l'occasion de saluer au
passage le liberté pour les 400 invités
ce devait être l'occasion de découvrir
les aménagements de la cité flottante
longue de 315 mètres prévus pour
recevoir 2400 passagers le fumoir des
premières classes par exemple qui occupe
toute la largeur du navire soit 32 mais
les cuisines dont il suffit de préciser
qu'elles sont à la mesure de ce futur
palace de l'atlantique
[Musique]
sous ce dôme étoilé qui la domine de 5
mètres cinquante de haut la salle à
manger
[Musique]
la salle de spectacle la plus grande qui
ait jamais été construite sur un navire
et qui possède une capacité de 664 place
tel est le luxe qassam town où il ne
faisait que le courte escale le france a
offert aux personnalités du corps
britanniques et notamment à son lord
maire féminin une prochaine croisière
aux canaries permettra d'apprécier un
peu plus ses qualités et ce sera enfin
ouverte la route de new york bonne
chance donc aux france
[Musique]
3 semaines ont déjà passé depuis que la
capitale du territoire de goa pas jim
est tombé au pouvoir des troupes
indiennes le président des roues ayant
acheté trente mille hommes sur la très
ancienne possession portugaise que
défend des 3000 hommes les portugais ont
été écrasés et goa est tombé au bout de
36 heures surmonter aujourd'hui des
couleurs indiennes l'ex résidence du
gouverneur portugais est devenu le
quartier général du chef de l'armée
d'occupation
[Musique]
on sait que goa vivait à l'ombre du
drapeau portugais depuis 450 ans si
l'apôtre traditionnel de la non violence
n'a pas hésité devant un coup de force
pour occuper goa à l'encontre de toute
loi internationale on peut se demander
que peuvent vouloir dire les
déclarations coutumière de monsieur
nehru touchant l'emploi de la force
[Musique]
à ce montant le pakistan dont karachi la
capitale offre le spectacle pittoresque
d'une ville que se partagent des images
contrastées d'un passé millénaire et
d'un présent très actuel s'émeut devant
certaines menaces venues de
concentration de troupes indiennes aux
abords de la frontière du cachemire le
souvenir semble bien passer des jours de
1953 où monsieur me roux venait rendre
visite au chef du gouvernement
pakistanais monsieur mohamed alliés le
temps des embrassades qui succédait à la
décision de l'onu réclamant un
plébiscite des populations des
cachemires plébiscite qui nous
d'ailleurs jamais lieu s'est rapidement
évanouie
le pakistan pays musulman craint de
revoir les jaunes 1947 où les forces
indiennes repris par la force possession
de territoires dont la population
musulmane voulait rejoindre l'état
pakistanais
l'intervention de l'onu en 1949 les
saints les adversaires en présence le
long d'une ligne d'armistice frontières
dont le provisoire dure encore depuis le
cachemire est resté entre les deux états
une pomme de discorde
monsieur nehru va-t-il vouloir à nouveau
trancher par les armes une vieille
querelle
[Musique]
et
vieux faire ta main les ogres que roger
louis dupuy a exposé dans une galerie
parisienne ne sont rien d'autre en effet
que de vieux outils ou de vieilles
ferrailles qu'il a glané un peu partout
mais il a ajouté à leur présentation ce
petit rien qui s'appelle
et ces vieux faire maintenant vive
un groupe de hachoir voici huit jeunes z
trois sacs de charrue des conspirateurs
elle gratte un pic facebook du guesclin
de fer à cheval et un gong vieilles
portes ferdinand le taureau
et
une colle à sable une pelle à foin a
derrière
[Musique]
et mme arthaud de géologues le que tout
cela
de cisailles de fil à plomb les clowns
mieux faire d'amore en effet et si peu
qu'on paie les substituer à des scènes
quotidiennes
soyez sages des mamans
[Musique]
l'auto stop
elle
un drain de conduite
le
la partie de pétanque
[Musique]
paris c'est un peu la capitale du
football breton il y avait près de 20000
bretons en effet sur les 35000
spectateurs du parc des princes pour
assister au match de coupe de france
rennes racing club de paris c'est sans
doute pour cela que les rennais maillot
français ont marqué le 1er but durant la
première mi temps ils ont donné
l'impression qu'ils pouvaient battre les
parisiens grâce à un football pas
compliqué mais efficace dans sa
conception
les choses ont changé en deuxième mi
temps
sur cette action cénacle numéro 10 tirs
au but et jacky bien placé dévie la
balle les parisiens gagnent
deux entrevues parisiens vont suivre
bien que les rennais net à aucun moment
baissé les bras bien au contraire
deuxième but dans un angle impossible
signé bollini et le troisième c'est
encore lui qui va le signer après une
descente de multi novik
3 ar le racing est qualifié pour les
seizièmes de finale
il ne s'agit pas là d'une autoroute
américaine ce réseau routier
ultramoderne est situé aux portes
d'abidjan abidjan carrefour du sport
africain à l'occasion des jeux de
l'amitié auquel ont participé également
les athlètes français la france se
devait d'apporter son concours à ses
amis d'afrique noire ainsi durant une
semaine abidjan s'est transformée en
capitale olympique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces magnifiques installations sportives
sont sortis de terre en moins de trois
mois ce qui constitue un exploit assez
rare le président houphouët boigny et
monsieur maurice herzog ont présidé
cette première grande confrontation du
sport africain et français
[Musique]
et maintenant défilé des délégations
pour marquer l'an 1 des jeux de l'amitié
qui deviendront peut-être un jour les
jeux olympiques de l'afrique noire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le palais des sports parisien est archi
comble pour le combat de poids moyens
vannes outils annexes
annexes toujours puissants se met
rapidement en action
panucci le corps son adversaire culotte
noire à bandes blanches qui a beaucoup
de supporteurs dans la salle lui impose
un combat violent rapide
[Applaudissements]
il ne s'agit pas là de deux stylistes
mais deux boxeurs de tempérament qui se
rendent coup pour coup
[Applaudissements]
ce travail de démolition réciproque ne
donne finalement aucun résultat les deux
boxeurs reste debout le combat va
jusqu'à la limite
il n'y a en définitive ni vainqueur ni
vaincu mais pour annexes l'issue de ce
combat aura été dramatique le verdict à
peine rendue on lui apprenait la mort
subite de son père
dans les arènes du pardo les aficionados
madrilènes ont participé bien malgré eux
au plus gros gag tauromachique de
l'année et pourtant il était venu avec
l'espoir d'assister à la consécration
d'un futur grand matador on le leur
avait dit du moins ce futur grand
matador candau baisse a rapidement
transformé la novillada en charlotade
c'est ce que nous lui pardonneront
jamais les amoureux de la corrida
il est vrai que sans vouloir cordoba
s'est moqué de revanche pour ceux qui ne
sont pas puristes le numéro de corde en
baisse ne manque pas de saveur
[Musique]
m
c'est peut-être là le début d'une
nouvelle vague de matador
dans l'arctique cordobès veut à tout
prix triomphé du taureau et demie
importe les moyens
[Musique]
dans cette aventure cordobès a au moins
gagné une chose il a mis les rieurs de
son côté
[Musique]